je m'appelle en moi vous aime la danse
classique les chopines les enduits ce
que je suis le type même de la turque
les scieries manning du sans histoire
salut je m'appelle walter mabille est
guidé par une seule passion danse et
j'ai ça dans la peau quand je marche
quand je bosse là dedans c'est ma vie je
lâcherai pas la faire mais enfin pense à
ton avenue l'avenir il n'est pas gravé
dans le marbre papa il s'invente à
chaque fois qu'est ce qui t'amène en
ville j'ai tout plaqué pour être danseur
professionnel
[Musique]
tu parles
lâchez moi avec cette fille juste une
bonne copie pourquoi tu m'a amené ici
il est plutôt beau garçon soit vertu
amoureuse maman tu accuses j'avais
quelque chose à dire je vais participer
aux européennes des jo
j'ai besoin du partenaire d'entraînement
[Musique]
m
anna après 20 ans d'absence est allé de
deux filles de qui je vais être honnête
le telegraph york est arrivé ce matin a
dit qu'il était mort maintenant je suis
désolé et devient l'entraîneur olivier
des rebelles tu penses qu'à toi j'étais
pas une peut-être que tu peut débarquer
sans fin comme la route
si tu veut m'aider à gagner le concours
règle des problèmes avec ton père
d'abord tu crois que c'est facile entre
notre relation compliquée revenant qui
débarque tu sais quand j'ai des
problèmes je danse sa règle rien et ça
me donne la force d'avancer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]